From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole sitting in for Ira Glass. This is not a story about bicycle theft. It's a story about a counterintuitive impulse exhibited by the human species in which a lot of bicycles happen to get stolen.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是肖恩·科尔，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。这并不是一个关于自行车被盗的故事，而是一个关于人类身上一种反直觉冲动的故事，很多自行车恰好就是在这种冲动下被偷走的。
The first bike belonged to a physical therapist named Carrie Helminger. This was in Seattle back in 2015. She rode her bike to work like always, locked it up securely like always. And when she came down to get it at the end of the day, it was gone. She felt about this how you might imagine.
第一辆自行车属于一位名叫卡莉·赫尔明格的理疗师。那是2015年的西雅图。她像往常一样骑车上班，像往常一样把车锁得严严实实。当她一天工作结束下楼去取车时，车不见了。她当时的感觉，你大概能想象得到。
Mad, you know? Like, why do you want my bike? And now, how am I going to get home? And it's late. And I'm tired and just frustrated, and pissed, and all that.
气坏了，你知道吗？就觉得，为什么你们要偷我的车？现在我怎么回家？天都晚了。我又累又沮丧，愤怒，诸如此类。
The cops were remarkably responsive, came right away. They were also deeply pessimistic. Said all the usual things-- you're not likely to get it back. We get reports like this all the time. There's really nothing we can do, unless something happens. Carrie wasn't sure what that meant, until something did happen. She was at work the next day, tending to her physical therapy patients, only checking her phone now and then between appointments.
警察反应非常迅速，马上就到了。但他们也非常悲观。说了所有那些老生常谈的话——你找回来的可能性不大。我们总是接到这类报案。除非发生什么转机，否则我们真的无能为力。卡莉不确定这意味着什么，直到转机真的发生了。第二天她在上班，照看她的理疗病人，只是偶尔在预约空档看一眼手机。
And I remember seeing this text from a number that I didn't know that just said something like, I may have found your bike. And I'm like, what? What do I do with that, you know? I don't know who you are. Is this a joke? Is this a scam? That was the thing that kept crossing my mind a lot, is, like, is this some weird scam?
我记得收到一条短信，来自一个我不知道的号码，上面写着类似“我可能找到了你的自行车”。我就想，什么？我该怎么处理这个，你知道吗？我不知道你是谁。这是个玩笑吗？这是个骗局吗？那件事一直在我脑子里打转，就是，这会不会是什么奇怪的骗局？
Were you trying to mathematically figure in your head how the scam might have worked, if it was a scam?
你当时有没有试图在脑子里从数学上计算一下，如果这是一个骗局，它会是怎么运作的？
I mean, I don't know how they would know it was me. So this is the thing that I kept trying to figure out. Like, would they steal my bike, and then know it's me, and then ask me for money? And then they'd make money on it. And they'd give me my bike back, and they've got $100 more or something?
我是说，我不知道他们怎么会知道是我。所以我一直试图弄明白的就是这个。他们会先偷我的车，然后知道是我，再向我要钱吗？然后他们从中获利。接着把车还给我，他们还多赚了100美元或者什么的？
Which Carrie says that would have been fine with her. It's better than having no bike. Anyway, she didn't know how to respond. Put the phone down, examined more hips and shoulders and knees, came back to another text.
卡莉说如果是那样她也能接受。总比没车强。总之，她不知道该怎么回复。放下手机，又检查了几个病人的髋部、肩膀和膝盖，回来又收到了另一条短信。
That said, was your bike stolen? I think I may have found it on Craigslist. And so I'm like, OK. So this is the same guy. More questions. And so I'm like, yes, it was stolen. Who are you? And then I think at that point, he probably responded and said, I was looking for a bike for my wife.
那条短信说，你的车被偷了吗？我想我可能在Craigslist上看到了它。所以我就想，好吧。原来是同一个人。更多的问题来了。所以我就回，是的，被偷了。你是谁？然后我想在那个时候，他可能回复说，我在为我妻子找自行车。
I was looking for a bike for my wife, and this ad came up on Craigslist-- real questionable.
我正在为我妻子找自行车，然后在Craigslist上看到了这个广告——看起来很可疑。
This is the guy who was texting. Dirk deGroot, works in marine construction, big cyclist himself. By questionable, he means the ad was poorly written and listed the bike for way less than it should have cost.
这就是发短信的那个人。德克·德格鲁特，从事海洋建筑工作，他自己也是个狂热的骑行者。他所谓的“可疑”，是指那个广告写得很烂，而且标价远低于它应有的价值。
A couple of blurry pictures taken at night. And you're thinking, who the hell takes pictures at night? So I did some googling, and I found Bike Index.
几张晚上拍的模糊照片。你就会想，谁会大晚上拍照啊？所以我上网搜了一下，找到了“自行车索引”（Bike Index）。
It's a site where people can register their bikes and report them stolen, as Carrie had done.
那是一个人们可以注册自行车并报告被盗的网站，就像卡莉做的那样。
He said, I saw that you posted it on Bike Index. And so I'm like, ah, this is starting to sound a little bit more legit. But I still have no idea who he is.
他说，我看到你在“自行车索引”上发布了信息。所以我就想，啊，这听起来更靠谱一点了。但我还是不知道他是谁。
I think we spoke probably around my lunch break. And he told me that he was maybe going to go get the bike. And I was like, what? And he was like, yeah. I remember him saying at one point, yeah, I'm kind of jazzed about this. I'm getting a little adrenaline high from this.
我想我们大概是在我午休的时候通的话。他告诉我他或许打算去把车拿回来。我当时就想，什么？他说，是的。我记得他当时说，嘿，我对这事儿挺兴奋的。这让我有点肾上腺素飙升的感觉。
And part of me is like, great, that solves that problem, if he wants to do that. But are you nuts? Why do you want to do that? And be careful. That would be the scariest thing for me. There's no way I would ever do that.
我一方面觉得，太棒了，如果他想那么做，那问题就解决了。但你疯了吗？你为什么要那么做？小心点。那对我来说是最可怕的事。我是绝不会那么做的。
Dirk did do it, arranged to meet the guy selling the bike. Except when he got to the appointed spot, unexpectedly, it was three guys, two more than him. He gives the bike a once over, careful to check out the serial number, which he'd gotten from Carrie. And sure enough, it's hers.
德克确实做了，他安排和卖车的人见面。但当他到达指定地点时，出乎意料的是，对方有三个人，比他多两个。他仔细检查了一下自行车，特意核对了卡莉给他的序列号。果然，就是她的车。
At this point, I had no idea what I was doing. I was like, oh, fuck. Shit. [LAUGHS] OK, I've got this piece of paper in my hand with the serial number, and I'm looking at these three guys. And I'm holding an allen key, and I'm like, oh, God.
那一刻，我根本不知道自己在做什么。我当时想，噢，该死。惨了。[笑声] 好吧，我手里拿着写有序列号的纸条，看着这三个人。手里还拿着一把内六角扳手，我想，噢，天哪。
So he takes out his phone, kind of subtly dials 911, and the call won't go through. No signal.
所以他掏出手机，有点不动声色地拨打911，但电话打不通。没信号。
So I lied, and I was like, yeah, well, that was the cops, guys. They're on their way.
所以我撒了个谎，我说，嘿，那是警察，伙计们。他们马上就到。
And as if there were ever any doubt as to the provenance of the bike, one of the guys, at the very mention of the police, just takes off running.
仿佛对自行车的归属还有任何疑问似的，其中一个人一听到警察这两个字，转身就跑。
So he scoots off. And there's two guys, and they're both sitting there, a little agitated. They don't know if I'm lying. And Seattle's pretty steep, so I'm thinking, maybe I could Sparta kick one of these guys down the hill.
他溜之大吉了。剩下两个人，他们都坐在那里，有点不安。他们不知道我是不是在撒谎。西雅图的地势很陡，所以我心想，或许我可以把其中一个家伙像斯巴达勇士那样踹下山去。
Sparta kick.
斯巴达踢。
I was like, I don't know what I'm going to do with the other one. I'm tall, but I've had my ass kicked so many times. My friends will tell you, I'm not a very good fighter.
我当时想，我不知道该怎么对付另一个。我个子高，但我挨过太多揍了。我的朋友们会告诉你，我不是个好的打架斗殴者。
And then, after several long moments with the three of them just kind of staring at each other, as though bidding farewell to a couple of drinking buddies for the evening, Dirk says--
在他们三个人面面相觑僵持了很久之后，就像晚上告别几个酒友一样，德克说——
Well, guys, we're in kind of a stalemate. I'm just going to take it. Threw the bike in the back of my truck.
好吧，伙计们，我们现在僵住了。我就直接拿走了。然后把自行车扔进我的皮卡车后座。
And then calls. It's your bike. I have it. Where should I meet you? And I'm like, what? I just was so excited.
然后打电话。那是你的车。我拿到了。我在哪儿见你？我当时想，什么？我太激动了。
He pulls up, then he pulls my bike out. And I'm, that's my bike. And he's like, here you go. (LAUGHS) It's like, can I pay you? What do you want? He's like, no, you don't need to pay me. It's fine.
他把车开过来，然后拿出我的自行车。我心想，那是我的车。他说，给你。 [笑声] 我说，我能付钱给你吗？你想要什么？他说，不，你不需要付钱给我。没关系。
I mean, it just was really crazy to me that the night before, I'm heartbroken. My bike is stolen. And the next night, I can ride my bike home already. It just felt weird.
我是说，这对我来说真的很疯狂，前一天晚上，我还心碎欲绝。我的车被偷了。而第二天晚上，我已经能骑车回家了。感觉真不真实。
Which brings me to what the story is about-- the fact that Dirk's actions, while seeming to come totally natural to him, made no sense from the outside, even to the person who directly benefited from those actions. Carrie's brain could not stop trying to make sense of it, even as she rode away that night.
这就引出了这个故事的主题——事实上，德克的行为，虽然在他看来完全是出于本能，但从外部看却毫无道理，甚至是对于那些直接受益于这些行为的人来说也是如此。卡莉的大脑在那个晚上骑车离开时，依然无法停止试图理解这一切。
You just did this huge, amazing thing for me that was incredibly kind, and I'm still very cautious of who you are. I don't know. Maybe that speaks more of me and the cautious nature, or I don't know [INAUDIBLE].
你刚刚为我做了这么巨大、了不起的事情，简直太善良了，但我仍然对你是谁非常谨慎。我不知道。也许这更多地反映了我的谨慎本性，或者我不知道 [听不清]。
Or it speaks to how just unusual it is.
或者也说明了这有多么不同寻常。
Yes. Would somebody really do this? Would they go steal my bike back for me, and then bring it to me? Why would somebody do this? Why--
是的。真会有人这么做吗？有人会真的为我把车偷回来，然后送到我手里吗？为什么会有人这么做？为什么——
There's got to be a catch somewhere.
肯定有什么隐情。
There's got to be a catch, right? Yeah.
肯定有什么隐情，对吧？是的。
But there wasn't. Dirk just does stuff like this-- like if he's driving, and he sees a cyclist with a flat tire.
但并没有。德克就是喜欢做这种事——比如如果他在开车时，看到一个骑行者轮胎没气了。
I'm the idiot that stops on the side of the road. I'm like, do you need any help? And the guy's like, fuck off. No, weirdo. OK, well, let me know.
我就是那个在路边停下来的傻瓜。我会问，需要帮助吗？那个人就会说，滚开。不，怪胎。好吧，有需要再找我。
He likes helping people. He can still picture how happy Carrie looked when he dropped the bike off.
他喜欢帮助别人。他依然能想起当他把车送还给卡莉时，她看起来有多么开心。
She was just fucking, I mean, stoked-- absolutely elated. And seeing all this emotion on her face-- I'm not a very emotional guy, but I mean, I felt just a deep sense of accomplishment. And it felt just so good. That was a very specific feeling, you know?
她当时简直，我是说，太激动了——完全是欣喜若狂。看到她脸上的所有这些表情——我不是一个感情丰富的人，但我的意思是，我感到了一种深刻的成就感。感觉真的很好。那是一种非常特别的感觉，你知道吗？
It's the same feeling I now get when I come home from being gone for work for a week, and my son jumps down the stairs to hug me. It's like, oh, wow, this is great, you know? I love this so much.
这和我现在出差一周回到家，儿子跳下楼梯来拥抱我时的感觉是一样的。那种感觉，噢，哇，这太棒了，你知道吗？我太爱这种感觉了。
It sounds like you're describing appreciation.
听起来你在描述一种被认可的感觉。
Yeah. Yeah, I guess that-- hmm. That very well could be, you know? Just feeling appreciated might have been the trigger.
是的。是的，我猜那个——嗯。那很可能是，你知道吗？仅仅是感觉到被认可可能就是那个触发点。
The trigger to make you want to keep doing it?
让你想要继续做下去的触发点？
Yeah. Yeah, the trigger to make me want to keep doing that.
是的。是的，让我想要继续那样做的触发点。
And he did keep doing it. Before too long, he recovered a bike for a guy from Colorado, who had just moved to town. Like Carrie, the guy was very grateful to have his bike back. Then there was the college student who bought Dirk a six-pack of IPA after he rescued her bike for her. Dirk doesn't really drink beer, though. The systems administrator who mailed him an envelope of cash, which wasn't even the nicest part of it for Dirk.
他确实继续做了。没过多久，他又为一位刚搬到城里的科罗拉多州人找回了车。就像卡莉一样，那个人对找回自行车也非常感激。还有那位在他帮她找回自行车后，送了他一箱IPA啤酒的大学生。不过德克其实并不喝啤酒。还有那位给他寄了一封现金信封的系统管理员，这对德克来说甚至不是最好的部分。
I had his thank you card on my wall for my office for a long time.
很长一段时间，他的感谢卡都贴在我办公室的墙上。
His methods were pretty consistent-- always started with obsessively scrolling sites like Craigslist and OfferUp to see what bikes were for sale, and then cross-referencing those against the stolen bikes on Bike Index. Then he'd message the person selling the stolen bike and say he's interested in buying it. Sometimes, he'd give the cops a heads up and have them waiting nearby to swoop in at just the right moment. Other times, he just confidently and with an almost eerie calm say something like--
他的方法相当一致——总是从沉迷于浏览Craigslist和OfferUp等网站，看看有什么车在出售开始，然后将这些与“自行车索引”上被盗的自行车进行交叉比对。然后他会联系卖这辆被盗自行车的人，说他有兴趣购买。有时，他会给警察通风报信，让他们在附近埋伏，在关键时刻突然出击。其他时候，他只是自信且带着一种几乎令人毛骨悚然的冷静说一些类似的话——
Hey, I'm not accusing you of stealing this bike, I just know it's stolen. You may have stolen it-- don't care. And they would typically scoot off.
嘿，我不是在指控你偷了这辆车，我只是知道它是被偷的。你可能偷了它——我不在乎。然后他们通常就会溜之大吉。
It took him 10 recoveries before he really felt like he knew what he was doing. After the 20th one, a Seattle police detective who specialized in property crime gave Dirk his direct line, told him to always call and arrange for backup ahead of time.
他成功找回了10辆车后，才觉得自己真正知道自己在做什么。找回第20辆时，一位专门负责财产犯罪的西雅图警探直接给了德克他的专线电话，告诉他以后一定要提前打电话安排备份。
That sting, the 20th one, was significant in a lot of ways, actually. It wasn't just a bike theft, it was a home invasion. The thieves grabbed everything they could get their hands on. Dirk essentially cracked that case. One of the officers on duty that night looked at Dirk and asked him the perennial question.
那次钓鱼执法，也就是第20次，在很多方面其实意义重大。那不仅仅是一起自行车盗窃案，还是一起入室盗窃案。小偷把能拿到的一切都拿走了。德克基本上破获了那起案件。那天晚上值班的一名警官看着德克，问了他那个永恒的问题。
Like, why in the hell are you doing this? I was like, ah, it just feels really good to help these people. And he's like, oh, that's so interesting. You're like Robinhood. He goes, no, Robinhood robs from the rich and gives to the poor. I guess you're like Batman. And that was it. I mean, that was it. And they're like, oh, Bike Batman. I mean, it was sticky enough that it stuck.
比如，你到底为什么要这么做？我说，啊，帮助这些人感觉真的很好。他说，噢，那太有趣了。你就像罗宾汉。他说，不，罗宾汉劫富济贫。我想你更像蝙蝠侠。然后就是这样。我的意思是，就是这样。他们说，噢，自行车蝙蝠侠。我的意思是，这个名字很有粘性，就这么叫开了。
In fact, people are calling him Seattle's Bike Batman.
事实上，人们称他为西雅图的“自行车蝙蝠侠”。
Bike Repo Batman on roll against thieves.
打击窃贼的自行车蝙蝠侠。
They call him the Bike Batman here--
他们在这里叫他自行车蝙蝠侠——
I'm Batman.
我是蝙蝠侠。
The Bike Batman here in Seattle. And I think Brian Hansen--
西雅图的自行车蝙蝠侠。我想布莱恩·汉森——
The Seattle Times broke the story, followed by local TV and radio outlets, other newspapers and magazines. In all of the accounts, Dirk stayed anonymous. He only decided to unmask himself for this story, because he's not doing it anymore. He says he just hasn't had time for anything since his kids came along. But the newsworthiness of it was that someone would go so very far out of his way to retrieve property that wasn't his for people he didn't know. It was like the whole world had the same reaction as Carrie Helminger, the first person Dirk helped, who was mentioned in one of the magazine pieces.
《西雅图时报》报道了这个故事，随后是当地的电视和广播媒体，以及其他报纸和杂志。在所有的报道中，德克都保持匿名。他只决定为我们这个故事揭开面纱，因为他现在不再做这件事了。他说自从有了孩子后，他就没时间做任何事了。但这件事的新闻价值在于，竟然有人会为了找回不属于自己的财产，而为素不相识的人付出如此多的心血。就像整个世界对卡莉·赫尔明格——德克帮助的第一人——有着同样的反应，她在其中一份杂志的文章中也提到了。
I had to laugh because in the article, he writes, I think she thought I was a weirdo. And I'm like, uh-huh. Yup. Definitely, I thought you were a weirdo.
我不得不笑，因为在那篇文章里，他写道，我想她当时一定觉得我是个怪人。我心想，嗯哼。没错。我确实觉得你是个怪人。
Of course, the whole thing seems a lot less weird if you're Dirk deGroot. From his perspective, he figured out how to solve this problem. And once he figured it out, he couldn't not solve it, because no one else was doing it. He was like, somebody's got to do it.
当然，如果你是德克·德格鲁特，这一切看起来就没那么奇怪了。从他的角度来看，他找到了解决这个问题的方法。一旦他找到了，他就无法不去解决它，因为没有别人在做。他当时想，总得有人来做这件事。
I kind of knew what to do. And it was hard for people to-- people just didn't know. Do you know what to do if you find your bike stolen on Craigslist?
我多少知道该怎么做。而别人很难——人们只是不知道。你知道如果发现自己的车在Craigslist上被卖了该怎么做吗？
I actually can't think of a better way to spend your time on this planet than to identify something that's vexing someone else, or a lot of someone else's, and to put yourself into that gap between them and the solution. So today on our show, we're going to tell you about some remarkable people who do that, and why they do it, and how it goes, or doesn't go, for them. Stay with us.
我真的想不出比识别出令他人或许多他人感到困扰的事情，并让自己介入他们与解决方案之间的差距中，来度过余生更好的方式了。所以今天在我们的节目中，我们将向你讲述一些做这件事的非凡人士，以及他们为什么这样做，事情又是如何进展——或者不进展——的。请继续关注。
There's this image that's really stuck with a lot of us here at the show. You might have seen it. It's a photo of strollers, baby strollers, at a train station in Poland. In short, these Polish moms, anticipating a problem that Ukrainian refugee mothers might have when they cross the border clutching their little kids, started leaving strollers for them at different points of entry. In the photo, they're all lined up on the train platform-- some fancy, some not, some new, some with worn tires. Each one, a Polish family thinking about what could possibly be helpful when everything else is falling apart and providing it.
有一个画面真的深深印在我们节目组许多人的脑海里。你可能看到过。那是一张照片，波兰火车站的婴儿推车。简单来说，这些波兰妈妈们预见到乌克兰难民母亲们在抱着孩子跨越边境时可能会遇到问题，于是开始在不同的入境点为她们留下推车。照片里，它们都在火车站台上排成一行——有些豪华，有些普通，有些是新的，有些轮胎已经磨损。每一辆推车，都代表着一个波兰家庭在思考什么东西能真正提供帮助，在一切都分崩离析的时候，主动伸出援手。
Another problem that war has yielded, you've probably heard, is the lack of access in Russia to real accurate information about what's going on, the brutality of the war. Essentially, the Russian propaganda bubble tamping down on public opposition, which is what Act One of today's show is about. And it's about someone on a personal mission to solve that problem. We're calling this act, "Cold Call to Action." It's from producer Alix Spiegel.
战争带来的另一个问题，你可能听说过，就是俄罗斯国内缺乏获取关于正在发生的事情——战争的残酷性——真实准确信息的途径。本质上，俄罗斯的宣传泡沫压制了公众的反对声，这就是我们今天节目第一幕的内容。这是一个关于某个人执行个人使命来解决这个问题的故事。我们把这一幕称为“冷电话行动”。它来自制片人艾利克斯·斯皮格尔。
Paulius Senuta spent the first 13 years of his life in the USSR, so he knows how complicated it can be to live in a world with limited information. This was Lithuania in the '80s. And what Paulius remembers about living in that world is the distrust and the haziness. You had your suspicions, a creeping sense that there was something off about the news you were hearing, but there was no way to know for sure. And no one around you knew either.
保柳斯·塞努塔在苏联度过了他人生的前13年，所以他知道生活在一个信息匮乏的世界里有多复杂。那是80年代的立陶宛。保柳斯对那个世界记忆深刻的是怀疑和迷茫。你有你的猜测，一种不断蔓延的感官，觉得你听到的新闻有些不对劲，但你无法确定。周围的人也一无所知。
So after Putin invaded Ukraine, Paulius reached out to friends in Russia to talk about the war. These were educated people, well-read people. But the Russian version of what was happening made his blood run cold. The story they'd heard was that Russia was just trying to help with the genocide.
所以普京入侵乌克兰后，保柳斯联系了俄罗斯的朋友谈论这场战争。他们都是受过教育、博学的人。但俄罗斯对所发生之事的解读让他不寒而栗。他们听到的故事是，俄罗斯只是在帮忙制止种族灭绝。
There was genocide of Russian people going on all the time, and so we need to take out the government. If we will not do that, they are going to go on killing Russian people in there. So we have this neat, tiny operation, military operation, going on there. We're just taking out the government.
那时候一直在发生针对俄罗斯人的种族灭绝，所以我们需要铲除那个政府。如果我们不这样做，他们就会继续在那里屠杀俄罗斯人。所以我们只是在那里进行了一次干净、微小的军事行动。我们只是在铲除那个政府。
In the world Russians knew, there were no pregnant mothers dying on gurneys, no leveled cities, no dead civilians at all.
在俄罗斯人所知的世界里，没有死在担架上的孕妇，没有被夷为平地的城市，根本没有任何平民死亡。
Some of them tell me stories about Russians bringing in food and clothing for Ukrainians.
有些人甚至跟我讲俄罗斯人为乌克兰人提供食物和衣服的故事。
It was a whole parallel universe of information, constructed and policed by Putin. Paulius believes the foundations of that universe are more fragile than they look, that if the Russian people could really see, know what was happening in their name, Putin's Potemkin village might crumble. Someone needed to do something, so Russians could understand the real horror of the war they were fighting.
这是一个平行的信息宇宙，由普京构建和维护。保柳斯相信那个宇宙的基础比看起来更脆弱，如果俄罗斯人民真的能看到、知道以他们的名义正在发生什么，普京的“波特金村”可能会崩塌。必须有人做点什么，让俄罗斯人能理解他们所参与的战争究竟是多么可怕。
And then one day, Paulius was sitting in a meeting, and his phone began to buzz. It was a friend calling to say that he had an idea about how they might solve this "Russians don't know about the war" problem.
有一天，保柳斯正在开会，电话响了。是一个朋友打来的，说他有一个关于如何解决这个“俄罗斯人不知道战争”问题的主意。
Says, you know, Paulius, what's funny about Russia? I say, I don't know. There's nothing funny about Russia to me. And he says, they got their phone numbers public. So you just go online, and you can get a hold of those numbers, so we can call them.
他说，你知道吗，保柳斯，关于俄罗斯有什么有趣的事？我说，我不知道。对我来说俄罗斯没什么有趣的。他说，他们的电话号码是公开的。所以你上网就能查到那些号码，我们就能给他们打电话。
As they talked, the two began to piece together a plan. What if they built a website where you pushed a button and got the name and telephone number of someone somewhere in Russia? Russian speakers from outside Putin's sealed universe could call in, tell Russian people, one by one, person to person, all about what was going on.
谈话中，两人开始构思一个计划。如果他们建立一个网站，你只要按下一个按钮，就能获得俄罗斯某个地方某个人的姓名和电话号码，这会怎样？讲俄语的人可以从普京的封闭宇宙之外打入电话，一个人对一个人，向俄罗斯人民讲述正在发生的一切。
Paulius works in advertising. He spent his life trying to convince people to do something they do not currently feel a need to do. So he knew that hearing an authentic human voice making a passionate case can be a very powerful way to alter someone's behavior.
保柳斯从事广告行业。他一生都在试图说服人们去做那些他们目前并不觉得有必要做的事。所以他知道，听到一个真实的人声发表激情的陈述，是改变他人行为的一种非常强有力的方式。
Human authenticity has a lot of power in itself. Just the way it is. Hearing it from a person who's genuine is much more persuasive than reading it on the BBC News. It's much more likely to get through.
人类的真实性本身就具有巨大的力量。仅仅是它呈现的方式。听到一个真诚的人这样说，比在BBC新闻上阅读要更有说服力得多。它更有可能产生影响。
Still, Paulius wasn't sure that this was a good idea. So many Russian speakers outside the country were really angry. He worried he'd just be creating a tool for people to shout at each other. Paulius himself was struggling with his feelings about the Russian people.
不过，保柳斯并不确定这是一个好主意。太多身处国外的俄语人士非常愤怒。他担心自己只会创造一个让人互相谩骂的工具。保柳斯自己也在努力处理对俄罗斯人的复杂情感。
Do you see them as victims, or do you see them as complicit?
你认为他们是受害者，还是认为他们是同谋？
Oh, it's so difficult to distinguish those two things. It's so difficult to distinguish those two things. I'm trying to put all the sympathy I have into this. Is it coming from the fact that I think that's going to create a bridge, and I'm cynical? Or do I truly have sympathy?
噢，区分这两者太难了。真的太难了。我试图把我所有的同情都投入到这里面。这源于我认为这能建立一座桥梁的念头，还是我仅仅是出于一种愤世嫉俗？或者我是否真的有同情心？
Paulius didn't have a clear answer. What he knew was that the scheme had at least the potential to help shift the tide, so he put his doubts aside and decided to go forward.
保柳斯没有明确的答案。他知道的是，这个计划至少有改变局势的潜力，所以他放下怀疑，决定继续前进。
Look, Paulius, you can come up with all problems you want. You can make up problems that don't exist. But if you don't do anything, nothing will happen.
听着，保柳斯，你可以想出无数个问题。你可以编造出根本不存在的问题。但如果你什么都不做，什么都不会发生。
Paulius says that he and his colleagues worked around the clock for five days until the website, Call Russia, went live about a week and a half into the war. The landing page featured a large yellow button, which randomly generated Russian telephone numbers.
保柳斯说，他和同事们连续五天没日没夜地工作，直到“呼唤俄罗斯”（Call Russia）网站在战争开始后大约一周半上线。登录页面上有一个巨大的黄色按钮，可以随机生成俄罗斯的电话号码。
And the site was an immediate hit. Paulius says they logged 32,000 calls in the first two days. Still, it wasn't until late on launch day that Paulius himself was able to sit down and try out this idea. He pressed the yellow button, then called the number that appeared on his screen. The phone was answered by a man.
网站立即大获成功。保柳斯说他们在前两天记录了32,000次通话。不过，直到上线当天的深夜，保柳斯自己才有机会坐下来尝试这个想法。他按下了黄色按钮，拨通了出现在屏幕上的号码。电话被一个男人接听了。
I told him who I am, and he started shouting immediately. And I said, I don't wish anything wrong. I'm just an ordinary person trying to connect to people in Russia.
我告诉了他我是谁，他立即开始大吼大叫。我说，我没有恶意。我只是一个试图与俄罗斯人民沟通的普通人。
And I said, do you know what is happening there? And he shouted at me. I remember that very vividly. He shouted at me. They are killing us there, and we're trying to save them. And he said-- he cursed at me and he hang up the phone. So that was my first conversation.
我说，你知道那里正在发生什么吗？他冲我吼叫。我记得非常清晰。他冲我吼。他们在那里屠杀我们，而我们正试图去拯救他们。然后他说——他咒骂了我，挂断了电话。那就是我的第一次谈话。
A few calls later, Paulius heard the voice of a woman.
几个电话之后，保柳斯听到了一个女人的声音。
What I find on calls, most of women will talk humanly to me. But that lady, she was-- so that lady yelled at me, like, I don't know, probably seven minutes. And she was saying, do you know who I am? I'm saying, of course, I don't. I don't have a clue. I don't know which city I'm calling. Could you tell me, please? And she was-- I'm the daughter of Putin.
在通话中我发现，大多数女性会跟我进行人类般的对话。但那位女士——她对我吼了大概七分钟。她说，你知道我是谁吗？我说，当然不知道。我一点头绪都没有。我不知道我打到了哪个城市。你能告诉我吗？然后她就——我是普京的女儿。
(GASPS)
（倒吸一口凉气）
And now, I'm inviting my father to take care of you. Now I know she's not-- well, I guess she's not the daughter of Putin, OK? It can't be that coincidence, right? It can't.
现在，我正邀请我的父亲来收拾你。现在我知道她不是——好吧，我想她不是普京的女儿，对吧？不可能是那样的巧合，对吧？不可能。
But she started, like, playing her joke around. She's like, Daddy! There's a Lithuanian who wants to find about the war. And I was saying, madame, why are you doing that? I truly and genuinely want to talk with you about what is happening in Ukraine. Can you tell me what you know about it? And she was like, Daddy!
但她开始像是在演戏一样。她说，爸爸！有个立陶宛人想了解关于战争的事。我说，女士，你为什么要那样？我是真心实意地想和你谈谈乌克兰正在发生的事情。你能告诉我你知道的情况吗？然后她就一直喊，爸爸！
Paulius says that many of the calls have been like those-- unreceptive, hostile. But then, every once in a while, there's a different kind of call, like the man who answered the phone and, at first, seemed quite friendly.
保柳斯说，许多通话都是那样的——不接受、带有敌意。但是，偶尔也会有不同种类的通话，比如那个接听电话的男人，起初看起来非常友好。
Soft-spoken, polite. And I would just introduce myself. I told what I'm doing and what I want to talk about. And he kept going with me, nicely. But at the moment he understood what it is about, he shut up. But I could feel he is there.
声音轻柔、礼貌。我就介绍我自己。我说了我在做什么以及我想谈什么。他一直和气地跟我交谈。但当他明白这是关于什么的时候，他闭嘴了。但我能感觉到他还在那儿。
So Paulius went forward, told the man about the war. All the terrors that Paulius had seen on TV poured out of him.
所以保柳斯继续说下去，告诉那个人关于战争的事。保柳斯在电视上看到的所有恐怖景象都倾吐了出来。
So he didn't speak. I was saying those things for probably four or five minutes. He wasn't talking a word. And when I finished, interestingly, he said goodbye. It touched me. He felt he needed to say goodbye, which is such a polite thing to do, so.
他没说话。我说了大概四五分钟。他一个字也没说。当我说完时，有趣的是，他说再见。这触动了我。他觉得他需要说再见，那是一种非常有礼貌的做法，所以。
And you heard in his silence what?
你从他的沉默中听到了什么？
You hear a person breathing, but most probably something that you hear very clearly is fear. So I was shocked that fear has a sound. I can't tell you what's the sound of fear, but you can hear that.
你听到一个人在呼吸，但最有可能的是，你能非常清楚地听到恐惧。所以我很震惊，恐惧竟然是有声音的。我说不出恐惧是什么声音，但你能听到。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
（俄语交谈）
Busy.
占线。
The day we spoke, I watched Paulius make a bunch of calls to strangers in different parts of Russia. What struck me was the tedium. It felt like very bizarre geopolitical telemarketing.
我们交谈的那天，我看着保柳斯给俄罗斯不同地区的人打了一连串电话。让我印象深刻的是那种枯燥感。感觉就像非常离奇的地缘政治电话推销。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
（俄语交谈）
Wrong number.
号码不对。
There were a lot of dead-ends.
有很多死胡同。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
（俄语交谈）
Voicemail.
语音信箱。
But every once in a while, Paulius got through.
但每隔一段时间，保柳斯就能接通。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
（俄语交谈）
So he hang up the phone. He says he knows everything. OK, so that wasn't a good call.
他挂断了电话。他说他什么都知道。好吧，那不是一个好的通话。
Paulius makes calls like these several times a week. He spends hours on the phone. Sometimes, he gets people like the quiet man, listeners who connect. But mostly, Paulius says, people are screaming. And oddly, he thinks that those calls are the best.
保柳斯每周都要打好几次这样的电话。他在电话上花了好几个小时。有时，他会遇到像那个安静的男人一样的听众，能够建立连接。但大多数时候，保柳斯说，人们都在尖叫。奇怪的是，他认为那些通话反而是最好的。
To me, screaming people are actually the ones that we need to talk to.
对我来说，尖叫的人实际上才是我们需要去沟通的对象。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Because these are the supporters of what is going on. And you know, it's pleasing and nice for me to have that nice conversation with the other person that I had with several people. It's so nice to have that conversation with those people, but the goal is not about having a nice conversation, right? It's about some of the people that are persuaded that they're doing a good thing in Ukraine to understand that they're not doing a good thing in Ukraine.
因为这些人是正在发生的事情的支持者。你知道，能够和对方进行那种友好的对话确实让我感到愉快，我和几个人确实有过那样的交谈。能和那样的人交谈确实很好，但目标不是为了进行一次愉快的对话，对吧？目标是让那些坚信他们在乌克兰做的是好事的人，理解到他们并没有在做一件好事。
Paulius is realistic about what this approach will accomplish. He says about 75% of the Russian population supports Putin, and those people aren't going to suddenly take to the streets. But he figures he might nudge them a little so that, when they see their neighbors protesting, instead of reaching out to the police to let them know, they might pause, ask themselves if that's really the best thing to do. That's why even when someone is yelling, Paulius tries to persevere.
保柳斯对于这种方法能达到什么效果很有自知之明。他说大约75%的俄罗斯人口支持普京，这些人不会突然走上街头。但他觉得他或许能推动他们一点点，这样当他们看到邻居抗议时，他们就不会选择报警，而是可能会犹豫一下，问问自己这真的是最好的做法吗。这就是为什么即使有人在吼叫，保柳斯也会试图坚持下去。
Emotionally, how hard is it for you to withstand the screaming?
在情感上，承受那种尖叫对你来说有多难？
Oh, it's super hard. No, it is very hard. It is-- oh, my gosh. I don't know how to-- I mean, you really travel somewhere. You're in a different world.
噢，超级难。不，确实很难。这——噢，天哪。我不知道该怎么说——我的意思是，你真的去了什么地方。你进入了一个不同的世界。
Do you ever feel like it's not worth it, and you can't do it more?
你有没有觉得这不值得，或者你无法再继续下去了？
[EMOTIONAL] No. No, I-- they-- there's people who are going, fighting in Ukraine. There's people who's dying here. People are killed daily. There's like 10 people killed today in the bread line, standing in the bread line. [CRYING] How we cannot do a fucking call?
（充满感情） 不。不，我——他们——有正奔赴乌克兰战斗的人。这里有正在死去的人。人们每天都在被杀。就像今天有10个人在排队买面包时被杀了。[哭泣] 我们怎么能不打一个该死的电话呢？
Yeah.
是的。
Paulius told me he'd never know for sure whether anything he was doing made even a whit of difference. But even if these calls were a drop of water for a forest fire, Paulius still thought it was important to try.
保柳斯告诉我，他永远无法确定他所做的一切是否真的产生了哪怕一点点的改变。但即使这些通话对于森林大火来说只是一滴水，保柳斯仍然认为尝试一下很重要。
Most of the things people are doing, most probably will have very little or no impact at all. The other day, I was doing flowers together, paper flowers together with Ukrainian children. Does doing flowers with Ukrainian children will stop the war in Russia-- in Ukraine? Sorry. Most probably not. But that sense of people coming together and explicitly trying to do something, even if that's futile, it makes us, all of us, stronger.
大多数人们做的事情，很可能几乎没有或完全没有影响。前几天，我和乌克兰孩子们一起做纸花。和乌克兰孩子们一起做花能阻止俄罗斯在乌克兰的战争吗？抱歉。很可能不会。但那种人们团结在一起，明确地试图去做点什么的感觉，即使是徒劳的，也让我们所有人都变得更强大。
Paulius says, since the website launched, they've been tracking the countries where people were calling from. He told me that, at first, calls were mostly from where he was-- Lithuania. But soon, he and his colleagues noticed it was spreading, the idea hopping from one country to the next, until they saw that Russian speakers from all over the world were reaching out to the people inside Putin's bubble. They'd seen the same problem Paulius did, and they were all trying their best to solve it with him.
保柳斯说，自从网站上线以来，他们一直在追踪人们拨打电话的国家。他告诉我，起初，电话大多来自他所在的地方——立陶宛。但很快，他和同事们注意到它正在传播，这个想法从一个国家跳到下一个国家，直到他们看到全世界讲俄语的人都在联系普京泡沫内的人们。他们看到了和保柳斯一样的问题，他们都在尽最大努力和他一起去解决它。
Alix Spiegel is one of the producers of our show.
艾利克斯·斯皮格尔是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Two, "Zoo Unto Others." On the first day of the war, there were 30 visitors to the zoo in Kyiv, Ukraine. On the ninth day of the war, there were none, no paying visitors. That was the day Washington Post reporter, Siobhan O'Grady, and a couple of her colleagues went there to meet the zookeepers.
第二幕，“为他人而活”。战争的第一天，乌克兰基辅动物园有30名访客。战争的第九天，没有了，没有付费访客。那天，《华盛顿邮报》记者西沃恩·奥格雷迪和她的几位同事去那里采访了饲养员。
Siobhan had been wondering about the people in Ukraine who are still working while the country had been under siege. Not just military, but everyday workers-- pharmacists, grocery store employees. It's the same thought a lot of us have had about essential workers during the pandemic, except, in this case, there were literally bombs going off around them. She wanted to know what it was like to do their jobs now under what are probably the most extreme circumstances possible.
西沃恩一直在思考那些在国家处于围困中时仍然在工作的乌克兰人。不仅仅是军人，还有日常的劳动者——药剂师、杂货店员工。这和我们许多人在大流行期间对必要行业劳动者的想法一样，只不过在这个案例中，他们的周围确实有炸弹在爆炸。她想知道在目前可能是最极端的环境下工作是什么感受。
They went to the zoo in the afternoon for a few rushed hours before curfew. Siobhan said it was eerie-- the giant colorful giraffe statue at the entrance, after they had just passed through several checkpoints to get there. The winding paths were virtually empty.
他们在下午宵禁前匆忙去了几个小时的动物园。西沃恩说那感觉很怪——入口处那个巨大的五彩长颈鹿雕像，而在那之前他们刚刚穿过了好几个检查站。蜿蜒的小路几乎空无一人。
The zookeepers were keeping the animals inside, partly because of the cold, and also because the animals could be killed if they came out for some exercise at the wrong moment. The zoo is right near a military facility that might be targeted by Russian forces, and they were worried about errant missiles. In total, about 50 staffers out of the usual 375 had stayed behind to look after the animals. I ask Siobhan what was behind their decision to stick it out.
饲养员们把动物关在室内，一部分是因为寒冷，也因为如果它们在错误的时间出来活动可能会被炸死。动物园就在一个可能成为俄罗斯军队目标军事设施的附近，他们很担心流弹。总共有50名员工在平时的375名员工中留了下来照顾动物。我问西沃恩是什么促使他们坚持留下来。
The ones I spoke to didn't make it sound like a decision. It wasn't an option. The staff members really felt a responsibility to stay, and that that would be the way that they would spend the war.
我采访的人没有把它听起来像是一个决定。那不是一个选项。工作人员确实感到有留下的责任，这就是他们度过战争的方式。
Because there is no one else, right?
因为没有别人了，对吧？
Right.
没错。
If they left, what do you think would happen? Would there be anybody that would leap over the zoo wall to--
如果他们走了，你觉得会发生什么？会有什么人跳过动物园的墙去——
No, the animals would die.
不会，动物会死掉。
4,000 animals going to be locked away in their pens and enclosures, slowly starving to death, if dehydration didn't get them first. And not just anyone can do this job. It takes special skill and knowledge of the different animals' dietary needs. Some of the animals need to live at different temperatures than others. It's a hefty enough task during peacetime. And of course, lots of aspects of the job are different in a war zone.
4000只动物被关在它们的围栏里，如果脱水不先带走它们，它们就会慢慢饿死。而且不是随便什么人都能做这份工作。这需要特殊的技能和对不同动物饮食需求的了解。有些动物需要在与众不同的温度下生活。这在和平时期已经是项艰巨的任务了。当然，战争期间工作的很多方面都不同了。
First of all, the zookeepers are mainly living at the zoo, which they normally would not be doing. The staff moved some of their families in. The head of the zoo, Kyrylo Trantin, moved his elderly mother into the zoo with him in order to care for her and the animals.
首先，饲养员们基本上住在动物园里，这在平时他们是不会做的。员工们把他们的一些家人也接了进来。动物园园长基里洛·特兰廷把他年迈的母亲接进动物园和他住在一起，以便照顾她和动物。
Is it that they can't live at home? Or they just thought it was safer at the zoo?
是他们不能住在家里吗？还是他们只是觉得待在动物园更安全？
It's both. So in some cases, maybe they live in a part of town that could eventually be cut off or made very difficult to get between the zoo and home, in which case they would be separated from each other. And it's also that some of them live in neighborhoods that have already been targeted by strikes.
两者皆有。在某些情况下，他们可能住在一个最终可能会被切断或者往返动物园和家变得极其困难的区域，那样的话他们就会被迫分开。还有就是他们中有些人居住的社区已经成为了袭击的目标。
Are they sleeping with the animals?
他们和动物一起睡吗？
So every night, a staff member has been sleeping with the elephant, Horace, the elephant, to comfort him, because elephants are really sensitive, in general. They also have enormous ears and really good hearing. So the booms and the sirens have been especially upsetting to him, to the point that he's been put on sedatives.
所以每天晚上，都有员工陪着大象霍拉斯一起睡，给它安慰，因为大象通常真的很敏感。它们还有巨大的耳朵，听力非常好。所以爆炸声和警报声对它特别困扰，以至于它必须服用镇静剂。
And at night, he was apparently waking up, walking around, exhibiting signs of extreme stress. And they were so worried about him that one of the staff members has volunteered to just stay in there with him. And so when he gets stressed at night, they speak to him in a kind of calming voice. They feed him his favorite snacks of apples and things like that and just kind of talk him down after any booms, until he can go back to sleep.
而且在晚上，它显然会醒来，四处走动，表现出极端压力的迹象。他们非常担心它，以至于其中一名工作人员主动申请留在那里陪它。所以当它在晚上感到焦虑时，他们会用那种平静的声音跟它说话。给它喂它最喜欢的零食，像苹果之类的，然后在每次爆炸声后安抚它，直到它能重新睡着。
Some of the staffers and their families occasionally sleep in an aquarium that's still under construction-- underground, bunker-like. Siobhan told me you could see where, one day, hopefully, there'll be glass and fish. But right now, there are all kinds of cots with pillows and sleeping bags on them. Siobhan imagined how nice and cool it would be to hang out down there during the summer months, if and when they can finish building it.
一些员工和他们的家人偶尔睡在一个还在建设中的水族馆里——地下，像地堡一样。西沃恩告诉我，你能看出未来某一天，希望那里会有玻璃和鱼。但现在，上面放着各种各样的床垫、枕头和睡袋。西沃恩想象着如果能建成，在夏季躲在那里休息该有多凉爽和舒适。
Wait, wait. Slow, slow.
等等，慢点，慢点。
During their tour of the zoo, the zookeepers handed Siobhan an apple and showed her how to feed Horace, the elephant with sleep trouble.
在游览动物园期间，饲养员递给西沃恩一个苹果，教她如何喂养有睡眠障碍的大象霍拉斯。
Welcome to Kyiv zoo.
欢迎来到基辅动物园。
Hi.
嗨。
They visited Toni the Gorilla, who's also been agitated, not because of the explosions necessarily. He's had no interaction with guests and apparently misses it a lot. Got visibly excited when his handler finally showed up. Also spat out his lunch all over one of Siobhan's colleagues for some reason.
他们去看了大猩猩托尼，它也一直很烦躁，但不一定是由于爆炸。它一直没有和游客互动，显然非常想念这一点。当它的饲养员最终出现时，它表现得明显很兴奋。不知什么原因，还把午餐吐了西沃恩的一位同事一身。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
（俄语交谈）
In the administration building, one of the animal handlers was feeding a brand new baby lemur, this incredibly small, soft, delicate thing, especially compared to the chaos it was born into. They named him Bayraktar, which is a kind of Turkish drone that the Ukrainians are deploying against the Russians. They're thinking of naming his sibling, Javelin.
在行政大楼里，其中一名动物管理员正在喂一只刚出生的小狐猴，这东西极其细小、柔软、娇嫩，尤其是与它所诞生的混乱世界相比。他们给它起名叫“贝拉克塔尔”，那是一种乌克兰正在部署对抗俄罗斯的土耳其无人机。他们正考虑给它的兄弟姐妹起名叫“标枪”。
Siobhan asked the zookeepers which of the animals were the least concerned about all of the explosions and sirens. The crocodiles, they said, and the alligator. All they care about is eating.
西沃恩问饲养员哪些动物对所有的爆炸和警报最不关心。他们说，鳄鱼和短吻鳄。它们只关心吃东西。
But as interesting as she found the animals, it was really the people she was there to learn about. One of the zookeepers who interested her most was Ivan Rybchenko, who still commutes to the zoo from home on his bike.
但尽管她觉得动物很有趣，但她真正想了解的还是人。让她最感兴趣的饲养员之一是伊万·雷布琴科，他仍然骑着自行车从家赶到动物园上班。
And I was interested when I saw him, because he was feeding a banana to a giraffe. And the air raid sirens had just gone off. We could hear booms in the background. And both he and the giraffes just didn't react at all. They just continued with the feeding.
当我看到他的时候我很好奇，因为他正在给一只长颈鹿喂香蕉。空袭警报刚刚响过。我们能在背景音里听到爆炸声。他和长颈鹿完全没有反应。他们只是继续喂食。
And he was just being really gentle and sweet with the giraffe. And we were all kind of looking around, like, should we take cover? Do you think it's OK? And they were like, you know, we're just going to keep eating this banana.
而且他对长颈鹿真的很温柔、很甜蜜。我们都在环顾四周，心想，我们需要找掩体吗？你觉得安全吗？他们却说，你知道，我们要继续把这个香蕉吃完。
Hmm.
嗯。
So I asked him, why are you still here? He's a young man of fighting age. He's 33. Most guys his age have probably volunteered for the forces, or doing something more directly related to the war effort. But he didn't see it that way at all. I mean, he said that his responsibility is the giraffes, the deer, and the horses at the zoo. And his job is a public service, and that's his contribution to the fight.
所以我问他，你为什么还待在这里？他是一个正值服役年龄的年轻人。他33岁。大多数他这个年纪的人可能已经报名参军，或者在做一些与战争努力更直接相关的事情。但他一点也不那样看。我的意思是，他说他的责任是动物园里的长颈鹿、鹿和马。他的工作是一项公共服务，这就是他为这场战斗所做的贡献。
To the war effort.
为战争努力。
Yeah.
是的。
He really saw it that way.
他确实是那样看的。
He did.
他是。
Which is something Siobhan has seen a lot of, she says. The people who've chosen to stay and continue doing their jobs amid the fighting, all of them see what they're doing as their role in the defending of Ukraine. After all, along with staving off the day-to-day attacks, they also need to preserve any pockets of normalcy they can, the things they had before the invasion. And that will mean still having a zoo when the war ends one day.
这正是西沃恩所看到的许多情况。那些选择留下并在战斗中继续工作的人，他们所有人都认为自己在做的事情是他们保卫乌克兰职责的一部分。毕竟，在抵御日常袭击的同时，他们也需要尽可能保留他们所能拥有的正常生活的点滴，他们在入侵前所拥有的东西。这意味着当战争最终结束时，他们依然需要拥有一个动物园。
You can reach Siobhan's article for the Washington Post about the Kyiv zoo at washingtonpost.com.
你可以在washingtonpost.com阅读西沃恩关于基辅动物园为《华盛顿邮报》撰写的文章。
Coming up, being a voice for the voiceless in possibly the most macabre and yet literal meaning of that phrase. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，为无法发声者发声，这可能是这个短语最离奇却又最字面意义上的含义。当我们的节目继续时，芝加哥公共电台会在一分钟后播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole, in for Ira Glass. Today's program-- Well, Someone Had To Do Something-- stories about someone's stepping up, taking it upon themselves to tackle some problem, large or small, for the greater good, or just for a discrete few, because who else is going to? We've reached Act Three of our show. Act Three, "One Last Thing After I Go."
这是《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔，代替艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——嗯，总得有人做点什么——讲述的是某人站出来，主动承担起解决某个问题——无论大小——的故事，为了更大的利益，或者仅仅是为了少数人，因为如果不做还有谁会做呢？我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“我离开后的最后一件事”。
All the people tackling problems in the show up to this point identified themselves what needed to be done. In this next story, the person jumping into the fray never even conceived of the thing that he was ultimately asked to do by somebody else. Producer Aviva DeKornfeld explains.
目前为止节目中所有试图解决问题的人，都认同了需要做的事情。在下一个故事中，投身其中的人甚至从未想到过某人最终会要求他做那件事。制片人阿维瓦·德科恩费尔德解释说。
This all started a few years back as a joke in strange circumstances, yes, but definitely, it was not meant to be taken seriously.
这一切始于几年前一种奇怪情况下的玩笑，是的，但绝对，它并不是为了被认真对待。
Yeah, it was a joke, absolute joke. And I mean that literally.
是的，那是个玩笑，绝对是玩笑。我的意思是字面上的意思。
This is Bill Edgar, a private investigator in Queensland, Australia. And around the time of the joke, Bill had been looking into some financial matters for a client named Graham.
这是比尔·埃德加，澳大利亚昆士兰的一名私家侦探。大约在那个玩笑发生的时候，比尔一直在为一个名叫格雷厄姆的客户调查一些财务问题。
At the time, I didn't know he was terminally ill. It was not until a couple of months in that I was investigating and Graham told me he was terminally ill, and he hadn't got long to go. And then I got to know Graham quite well. And it was one of those things that you start to talk about death, the afterlife, what's going to happen, who's around. And it became apparent that he really had a job he just wanted done.
那时，我不知道他患了绝症。直到调查几个月后，格雷厄姆才告诉我他病危了，时日无多。然后我和格雷厄姆变得很熟。那又是那种你开始谈论死亡、来世、将会发生什么、谁会在身边的事情。很明显，他真的有一件他只想做完的事。
Graham told Bill he had something he wanted said at his funeral, stuff he wanted to be sure everyone would hear. He thought about making a video of himself giving his own eulogy, but worried his family wouldn't play it. This thing he had to say, it wasn't very funeral appropriate. So as a joke, Bill offered to crash his funeral and say whatever it was Graham wanted said.
格雷厄姆告诉比尔，他有话想在葬礼上说，他想确保每个人都能听到。他考虑过录制一段自己发表悼词的视频，但担心家人不会播放。他必须说的话，不太适合葬礼场合。所以作为一个玩笑，比尔提议去砸他的葬礼，替格雷厄姆说出想说的话。
I could see him-- his mind was ticking over.
我能看见他——他的脑子在转。
Really?
真的？
You could just see it.
你就能看得出来。
Like you could see him sort of register?
就像你能看到他那种反应？
Oh, yeah. Yeah, he had this thing about him where you could just see it. And I thought to myself, oh, did I just plant the seed? Or did the penny drop? Did something just happen then?
噢，是的。是的，他身上有种特质，你就是能看出来。我对自己说，噢，我刚才种下了种子吗？还是钱掉地上了？刚才发生了什么吗？
A couple of weeks later, Bill got a text from Graham basically saying, let's do it. Once I'm dead, you go to my funeral, and I'll prepare a thing for you to say.
几周后，比尔收到了一条格雷厄姆的短信，基本上是说，干吧。一旦我死了，你就去我的葬礼，我会准备好你要说的话。
I was in a cafe when I received the text. So I remember I was about to leave the cafe, but I ended up ordering another coffee and sitting there, going, how the fuck am I going to do this?
收到短信时我正在一家咖啡馆。记得我当时正要离开，但我最终又点了一杯咖啡坐在那里，心想，我该怎么他妈地去完成这件事？
Bill agreed to do it, and Graham explained the situation. After he'd gotten sick and become bedridden, his best friend, John, had started hitting on his wife, trying to sleep with her. Graham had even seen it happen a few times. His wife told John to knock it off, but he wouldn't stop. And Graham was too sick to really engage or do anything about it, but it made him really mad.
比尔同意了，格雷厄姆解释了情况。在他病重卧床后，他最好的朋友约翰开始调戏他的妻子，试图和她睡觉。格雷厄姆甚至亲眼目睹了几次。他的妻子让约翰别这样，但他没停。而格雷厄姆太虚弱，无法真正干预或做任何事，但这让他非常愤怒。
So this is what Graham wanted Bill to do-- go to his funeral, and when his best friend stood up to deliver his eulogy, Bill was to interrupt him and call him out for what he'd done. Graham eventually died, and Bill, a total stranger to the family, went to his funeral, armed with Graham's message written on a piece of paper. Bill was nervous. The service started.
所以这就是格雷厄姆要比尔做的事——去他的葬礼，当他最好的朋友站起来发表悼词时，比尔要打断他，当众揭穿他做过的事。格雷厄姆最终去世了，比尔作为家人的陌生人，带着格雷厄姆写在纸条上的讯息去了葬礼。比尔很紧张。仪式开始了。
It was a blur to start with. I mean, I was sweating, profusely. And I've got to say, it was-- you've got your time on your phone. And I'm looking at the clock, and I'm thinking, OK, his mate's about to do the eulogy. And I knew I had to get up within one minute, two minutes at most, to interrupt the eulogy.
起初一片模糊。我是说，我汗如雨下。我得说，那是——你的手机上有时间。我看着时钟，心想，好的，他的同伙准备发表悼词了。我知道我必须在一分钟、最多两分钟内站起来，打断悼词。
And his best mate stands up, and he starts blubbering and telling everybody how much he loves his best mate and starts talking about a certain particular time that they shared. And it was that moment, I looked at my clock, and I went, oh, it's nearly two minutes in.
然后他最好的哥们站了起来，开始痛哭流涕，告诉所有人他多么爱他最好的朋友，开始谈论他们分享的某个特殊时刻。就在那一刻，我看了看时钟，心想，噢，已经快两分钟了。
And in that church, there were long pews. And they were timber. So when you stood up or you even moved, they made a sound. And yeah, when I stood up, it made a sound. And obviously, everyone just looked straight at you, you know? I froze, to say honestly. I stood up, and I just stood there and went, OK.
那个教堂里有长椅。它们是木制的。所以当你站起来或移动时，会发出声音。是的，当我站起来时，发出了声音。显而易见，每个人都直勾勾地看着你，你知道吗？老实说，我僵住了。我站起来，就在那儿站着，心想，好吧。
Bill started reading what Graham had written out for him.
比尔开始朗读格雷厄姆为他写的东西。
My name's Bill Edgar, and I'm here on behalf of the deceased, who has a message for you all. John, it's Graham here. I've hired Bill to interrupt your eulogy to tell you that I witnessed you on several occasions trying to screw my wife. God love her, she rejected every one of your advances. But that doesn't change the fact--
我的名字叫比尔·埃德加，我代表逝者在此，他有一条讯息给你们所有人。约翰，我是格雷厄姆。我雇了比尔来打断你的悼词，告诉你我曾多次亲眼目睹你试图勾引我的妻子。天佑她，她拒绝了你的每一次挑逗。但这并不能改变事实——
The best friend, John, speed walked out of the church. Bill heard some people whispering, telling him to sit down. But Bill had a job to do. There was more to read.
最好的朋友约翰，快步走出了教堂。比尔听到有些人低语，叫他坐下。但比尔有任务在身。还有更多要读。
If my brother, his wife, and their daughter are here, you can kindly fuck off, too. I haven't seen you in 30 years, and now you show up to pay your respects. Where were you when I was alive and could have used you around in the hard times?
如果我的兄弟、他的妻子和他们的女儿也在这里，你们也可以好心地滚蛋了。我30年没见过你们了，现在你们出现来表示敬意？当我活着且在困难时期需要你们的时候，你们在哪儿？
The brother, along with his wife and their daughter, quickly left the church, as well.
那个兄弟，连同他的妻子和女儿，也迅速离开了教堂。
You could hear a lot of whispering within the mourners, you know? And some mourners are sitting there, going, oh, fuck you. I don't know why she was here anyway, you know? And I'd be like, oh, cool. At least, they're on my side, you know?
你能听到悼念者中间有很多窃窃私语，你知道吗？有些悼念者坐在那里，心想，噢，去你妈的。我不知道她为什么在这儿，你知道吗？我会想，噢，酷。至少他们站在我这一边，你知道吗？
As quickly as it started, it ended. Bill folded up the paper, put it on top of the coffin, and walked outside to his car. His shirt was soaked through with nervous sweat. He was worried angry relatives might come after him. But at the same time, he was pretty clear on how he felt about the whole thing.
开始得有多快，结束得就有多快。比尔折好纸条，放在棺材上，走到车边。他的衬衫被紧张的汗水浸透了。他担心愤怒的亲戚可能会找他麻烦。但与此同时，他对整个过程的感觉非常明确。
Did you like doing it?
你喜欢做这件事吗？
Fuck, yeah. [LAUGHS] Absolutely.
妈的，当然。[笑声] 绝对喜欢。
Really?
真的？
I thought it was brilliant. You know what I loved most? Walking out. I thought that was just-- like, Graham had the mic drop, which is something that not many people get to do, you know? I had the ultimate experience of just walking away from it all and not even knowing what happens in the aftermath.
我觉得太棒了。你知道我最喜欢什么吗？走出去的那一刻。我觉得那简直——就像格雷厄姆丢了个麦克风，这是没多少人能做到的事，你知道吗？我得到了那种潇洒走开、甚至不知道后续发生了什么的终极体验。
So I'm just walking out, and I'm going to my car. And I only just made it to the car when a young girl came running up to me and said that-- her exact words were, Bill? Bill? Dad would have loved that. Thank you, so much. Mom's very grateful, which was really cool, you know? And she had another friend with her.
我就走着，朝我的车走去。我刚到车边，一个年轻女孩就跑向我，说——她的原话是，比尔？比尔？爸爸会喜欢那样的。谢谢你，太谢谢了。妈妈非常感激，这真的很酷，你知道吗？她还带了另一个朋友。
And not too much later, that friend reached out to Bill.
没过多久，那个朋友联系了比尔。
And she said, here, my auntie needs to see you, and she needs to see you now. Here's my number. Please give me a call as soon as you can.
她说，在这儿，我阿姨需要见你，她现在就需要见你。这是我的号码。请尽快给我打个电话。
Oh, wow.
噢，哇。
Yeah. Prior to the funeral, I thought, oh, this is just going to be a one-off thing, and I'm just going to walk away, and-- but it wasn't.
是的。葬礼之前，我心想，噢，这只是一次性生意，我走开就行了——但并非如此。
The aunty, Christine, she was dying of leukemia. And she was secretly in love with her best friend, Carol. Bill did her funeral, and then another, and another.
那个阿姨，克里斯汀，当时正死于白血病。她秘密地爱着她最好的朋友卡罗尔。比尔主持了她的葬礼，然后是另一个，又一个。
Enough people started reaching out to Bill that he figured he should really pick a name for himself, make this all a bit more official. So he decided on the Coffin Confessor. Bill's done a bunch of confessions at this point. People pay him to do it, and he likes the work. It suits him.
越来越多的人开始联系比尔，他想他真的应该给自己起个名字，把这件事弄得正式一点。于是他决定叫“棺材忏悔者”。比尔现在已经做了很多忏悔。人们付钱让他做这件事，他很喜欢这份工作。这很适合他。
Bill is a man who is constitutionally opposed to artifice. As a private investigator, he sees how messy people's lives really are, so he hates all the pomp and rituals candy coating most funerals. It feels phony. He thinks it's better when people tell the truth, whatever that truth may be.
比尔是一个从本质上反对造作的人。作为一名私家侦探，他看到了人们的生活究竟有多混乱，所以他讨厌大多数葬礼上那层糖衣般的排场和仪式。感觉很虚伪。他认为人们说出真相会更好，无论那真相是什么。
People say funerals are for the living. Bill thinks that's all wrong. Why shouldn't the dead get a say in how they leave this world? It's their funeral.
人们说葬礼是为活着的人准备的。比尔认为全错了。为什么死者不能在他们如何离开这个世界这件事上有发言权呢？那是他们的葬礼。
People hire Bill to confess all kinds of things. Sometimes, it's nice stuff. They just want to tell their family they love them one last time. One time, a client asked Bill to interrupt his funeral to apologize to his ex-wife and tell her how much she meant to him. That one went well. Other times, it's something petty. Someone wants to literally get the last word.
人们雇佣比尔去忏悔各种各样的事情。有时是很好的事情。他们只是想最后一次告诉家人他们爱他们。有一次，一个客户让比尔打断他的葬礼，向他的前妻道歉，并告诉她她在自己心中有多重要。那次进行得很顺利。其他时候，则是些琐事。有人想真真切切地拥有最后发言权。
One guy, an atheist, hired Bill to interrupt his funeral, which he knew his parents would turn into a religious affair against his wishes, to say, this is not what I wanted. That one did not go over so well.
有一个家伙，是个无神论者，雇了比尔打断他的葬礼，他知道他父母会违背他的意愿把葬礼变成一场宗教仪式，他想说：这不是我想要的。那次进行得并不顺利。
And occasionally, he's asked to reveal something darker, like with this one recent client, who hired Bill to confess that he'd been having an affair with a neighbor for the past two years, the effect of which would be, this guy's wife would learn at his funeral, in front of everyone, that he'd been cheating on her. In cases like that, Bill encourages the person to maybe say that themselves before they die.
偶尔，他也会被要求揭露更黑暗的事，就像最近那个客户，他雇佣比尔去忏悔他过去两年一直在和邻居偷情，其效果就是，这个家伙的妻子会在他的葬礼上，当着所有人的面，得知他在背着她出轨。在这种情况下，比尔会鼓励那个人在死前或许亲自去说。
Obviously, when I sit with him and I say to him, does your wife know? No. Are you going to tell her? Well, no, but I'll leave that to you. I mean, obviously, I'll say to him, yeah, it'd probably be nice coming from you.
显而易见，当我和他坐在一起说，你妻子知道吗？不。你要告诉她吗？嗯，不，但我会留给你去做。我的意思是，显而易见，我会对他说，是啊，如果由你亲自说出来可能会更好。
So you'll say that?
所以你会那么说？
And he'll say-- oh, yeah, absolutely.
他会说——噢，当然，绝对。
And how does that usually go over?
那通常进展如何？
No, it never goes over. It's just basically, this is what I've written. This is what you're going to do. Do it.
不，进展不下去。基本上就是，这就是我写的。这就是你要做的。去做吧。
Because it's easier to have you do it.
因为让你做比较容易。
Absolutely.
绝对。
In all the funerals Bill's crashed, there's one that sticks with him. This biker guy reached out to Bill, said he had cancer and that he was interested in hiring him. So Bill drove to the biker's home to meet him. He was this huge, muscley guy covered with tattoos.
在比尔砸过的所有葬礼中，有一场让他印象深刻。一个骑手找到了比尔，说他得了癌症，他有兴趣雇佣他。所以比尔开车去了那个骑手的家去见他。他是个高大、肌肉发达、浑身纹身的家伙。
Well, actually, when he first saw me he said, you? He said, you're the Coffin Confessor? I said, yeah, mate. You got a problem? And he says, no, not yet. And I said, OK.
嗯，事实上，当他第一次见到我时他说，你？他说，你就是棺材忏悔者？我说，是啊，伙计。你有问题吗？他说，还没。我说，好吧。
So I walk up to the balcony. I sit with him. And he goes, well, you crash funerals, so I want you to crash mine. Mine will be a burial. It's in the lawn cemetery. He said, and I want you to out that I'm gay. And I said, yeah, right, as a joke? And he says, why? Did I say it as a joke? And I said, OK. I said, so you're gay? And he goes, well, I'm bisexual. And I said, OK, cool.
所以我走向阳台。我坐下来。他说，好吧，你砸葬礼，所以我想要你砸我的。我的是土葬。在草坪公墓。他说，我要你公开我是同性恋的事实。我说，是啊，开玩笑吗？他说，为什么？我说笑话吗？我说，好的。我说，所以你是同性恋？他说，嗯，我是双性恋。我说，好，酷。
A few months later, the biker dies. As planned, Bill heads to the funeral and waits for his moment to jump in. He stands up midway through the ceremony and reads a letter he was given.
几个月后，那个骑手去世了。按计划，比尔去了葬礼，等待他介入的时机。他在仪式进行到一半时站起来，读了一封他收到的信。
Hi, dickheads. I'm dead, and you're all still here. Make sure you enjoy what time you have left. Death is a fucking scary adventure. I embraced it-- had to, really. I don't have much of a choice now, do I?
嘿，蠢货们。我死了，你们都还在这儿。确保你们享受剩下的时间。死亡是一场他妈的恐怖冒险。我拥抱了它——不得不拥抱，真的。我现在没什么选择了，不是吗？
Now that I'm gone, I've got something to tell you all. As some of you have known deep down, or suspected, I was bisexual. I was in love with a man, and that man stands amongst you right now. I know you're all looking around trying to figure out who he is. You're not going to ever know, unless he tells you. But I want you to know I loved him with everything I had.
既然我走了，我有事要告诉你们所有人。正如你们有些人深知或怀疑的那样，我是双性恋。我爱上了一个男人，而那个男人现在就站在你们中间。我知道你们都在环顾四周试图弄明白他是谁。你们永远不会知道，除非他告诉你们。但我希望你们知道，我用我所拥有的一切去爱他。
No, it's not David, who, right now, is probably standing up at the back, laughing and looking around. You can all stop looking at David. To those who cared for me, I love you guys. To those that didn't, I'll see you in hell. It's time for me to visit past family and friends. So live well, ride safe, and be true to yourself. That's something I wasn't, but wish I was.
不，不是大卫，他现在可能正站在后面笑，环顾四周。你们都可以停止看着大卫了。对于那些关心我的人，我爱你们。对于那些没关心过的人，地狱里见。是时候去探访过去的朋友和家人了。所以好好生活，骑车安全，对自己真诚。那是我没做到的，但我希望我能做到。
It's so easy to not say the thing you want to say, to go for years, even a lifetime, not finding the right words or the right moment. Sometimes the right moment is the last one, one final thing to shout over your shoulder into the party, as you're walking out the door.
说出你想说的话真的太难了，去经历数年，甚至一生，都找不到正确的词汇或正确的时刻。有时正确的时刻就是最后一个时刻，作为你走出门口时，回头向派对大喊的最后一件事。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers of our show.
阿维瓦·德科恩费尔德是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Four, "A Funny Thing Happened When We Were Already AT the Theater." This last story is a counterexample of sorts where you'd be forgiven for thinking, did somebody have to do something? Or anyway, that's what a lot of people thought in this case. Chana Joffe-Walt has the story.
第四幕，“当我们在剧院里已经发生了一件有趣的事”。最后一个故事算是一个反例，你会因为心想“总得有人做点什么吗？”而被原谅。或者无论如何，这是许多人在那个案例中的想法。查娜·乔菲-沃尔特讲述了这个故事。
Here's what happened. A group of people went to a movie theater near Los Angeles to see The Lost City. It was a 7:00 PM showing, but the projector was broken, so everyone in the audience was stuck waiting-- 10 minutes, 20. And then a woman from the audience walked down to the front of the theater in front of everyone and started doing standup.
事情是这样的。一群人去洛杉矶附近的一家电影院看《迷失之城》。那是晚上7点的场次，但放映机坏了，所以观众里每个人都被困在等待——10分钟、20分钟。然后一位观众中的女性走到剧院前台，当着所有人的面开始做单口喜剧。
So I am a single mom. Are there any single moms in the house?
所以我是个单亲妈妈。这里有单亲妈妈吗？
Any single moms in the house, she says. There's short clips of this online. She's in a beige dress, long, straight hair, waving her arms all over the place, trying to project her voice to the back of the theater. The act is chaotic and hard to follow. She's pretty all over the place.
她说，这里有单亲妈妈吗？网上有这部分的简短片段。她穿着一件米色连衣裙，留着长长的直发，双臂四处挥舞，试图让她的声音传到剧院后方。表演混乱且难以跟上。她表现得很狂乱。
I believe in Buddha. Jesus was never married.
我相信佛陀。耶稣从未结婚。
She does voices.
她模仿声音。
He-he-he-he-he!
嘻嘻嘻嘻嘻！
She chants.
她诵经。
Anybody here chant? [CHANTS]
这里有人诵经吗？ [诵经]
And she sings.
她唱歌。
(SINGING) [INAUDIBLE]
（歌唱） [听不清]
These are people who showed up to see Sandra Bullock and Channing Tatum roam around in the jungle. Instead, they got this.
这些人是来看桑德拉·布洛克和查宁·塔图姆在丛林里探险的。相反，他们得到了这个。
[SINGING OPERA]
（歌剧演唱）
There are tweets from audience members who are not happy about that switch. One of them says, a woman has decided to try her standup out on us. It's not good. Another one says, I want to crawl out of my skin and die. In one of the videos posted online, you can hear someone in the audience actually interrupt her act to yell, put us out of our misery!
推特上有观众对这种转换不满意。其中一个说，一个女人决定尝试对我们进行单口表演。这不好。另一个说，我想从我的皮肤里爬出来然后去死。在网上传出的其中一段视频里，你可以听到观众中有人打断她的表演，大喊，结束我们的痛苦吧！
Can you put us out of our misery, please?
你能让我们从痛苦中解脱出来吗，求你了？
Put us out of our misery? Aw.
结束我们的痛苦？噢。
The woman's response-- this is what got me-- she says--
这个女人的回应——这让我着迷——她说——
Do you want to come down here and try to entertain people?
你想下来试试娱乐大众吗？
Do you want to come down here and try to entertain people, as if entertaining everyone in this theater was a job someone obviously had to do.
你想下来试试娱乐大众吗，就好像娱乐剧院里的每个人是某个显然必须做的工作一样。
So walk me through the thinking of nominating yourself to be the one to do that.
那么带我梳理一下你自己提名成为那个去做这件事的人的想法。
I'm just very outspoken. Like, I have no problem talking to people. I don't get nervous in front of crowds. So I just felt like nobody else was going to, so I might as well try to communicate with everyone.
我只是非常直言不讳。比如，我跟人说话没问题。我在人群面前不紧张。所以我只是觉得既然没别人会做，那我不妨尝试跟每个人沟通。
The woman's name is Tiffany King. She's 42 years old, Latina, lives in Los Angeles. She has one eight-year-old daughter. She does many things-- waitresses, sings. She does college online and sometimes does standup.
那个女人的名字叫蒂芙尼·金。她42岁，拉丁裔，住在洛杉矶。她有一个八岁的女儿。她做很多事——当服务员、唱歌。她在线上大学，有时做单口喜剧。
And the way Tiffany King ended up performing unsolicited comedy that night-- there's the story on the internet, and then there's her story, which is different. Tiffany says she took her daughter to the movies that night.
关于蒂芙尼·金那天晚上如何最终表演未经请求的喜剧——网上有那个故事，然后有她的故事，那是不同的。蒂芙尼说那天晚上她带女儿去看电影。
So we got there, and the movie wasn't starting. And I was getting only annoyed. I was getting annoyed because my daughter had school the next day, and I'm like, OK, when is this movie going to start?
我们到了那儿，电影没开始。我变得很恼火。我变得恼火是因为我女儿第二天还要上学，我就想，好的，这部电影什么时候开始？
Everyone was just sitting around, Tiffany says, waiting. So she turns to her daughter and says, wouldn't it be funny if I go introduce the movie, like I'm with the theater? Do it, her daughter says.
蒂芙尼说，每个人都只是坐在那儿等。所以她转向女儿说，如果我像是在剧院工作那样去介绍电影，那会不会很有趣？她女儿说，做吧。
So Tiffany gets up in front of everyone. Hello, welcome to the theater. We're so glad to have you. The show will be starting shortly. And then she says, just kidding. I'm a comedian. But I do hope you all have good night, and she sits down. But then they're still waiting, and waiting, and nobody's doing anything.
所以蒂芙尼走到每个人面前。嘿，欢迎来到剧院。我们很高兴你们能来。演出很快就会开始。然后她说，开个玩笑。我是个喜剧演员。但我确实希望你们都有个美好的夜晚，然后她坐下了。但他们依然在等，一直等，没人做任何事。
So Tiffany gets up again, decides, I'm going to go find out what's going on. She goes down to the lobby. A guy tells her the projector's broken. They're working on it. She told them, we're sweating like crazy in there. The guy says they'd work on the AC. Then, Tiffany says, she went back to the theater and walked up front just to tell everyone what was going on. She said the projector's broken. They're working on it. They know we're hot in here. They'll try to get the AC back.
所以蒂芙尼又站起来，决定，我要去弄清楚发生了什么。她去了大堂。一个家伙告诉她放映机坏了。他们正在抢修。她告诉他们，我们在里面热得要命。那个家伙说他们会修空调。然后，蒂芙尼说，她回到剧院走到前台只是为了告诉大家发生了什么。她说放映机坏了。他们正在修。他们知道我们很热。他们会尽量恢复空调。
And then there was a Latino couple in the front. And the guy goes, oh, hey, if you're a comedian, can you tell us some jokes? And I was like, sure. And I don't even remember hesitating, because I like to help. [LAUGHS] And it makes me happy to make people happy, so I was like, OK.
然后前排有一对拉丁裔夫妇。那个男的说，噢，嘿，如果你是喜剧演员，你能给我们讲几个笑话吗？我就说，当然。我甚至不记得犹豫过，因为我喜欢帮忙。[笑声] 让人们开心让我感到快乐，所以我说，好的。
And what did it feel like when you started telling jokes?
那么当你开始讲笑话时感觉如何？
Honestly, I was just pulling random clean jokes. I was just trying to string together some clean jokes that would not be inappropriate for my daughter.
老实说，我只是在胡乱讲些干净的笑话。我只是在试图串联一些对女儿来说不失礼的干净笑话。
So she went with a truly random collection of jokes. And from Tiffany's perspective, it was going fine. People were laughing, clapping.
所以她选了一组真正随机的笑话。从蒂芙尼的角度来看，一切进行得很顺利。人们在笑、鼓掌。
And everything was going-- everything felt great, until the girl heckled me. And she was like, please, no. Put us out of our misery.
一切都很顺利——直到那个女孩对我进行嘘声。她说，拜托，不要。结束我们的痛苦吧。
It was only the next day that Tiffany learned some of her audience had not appreciated being subjected to an unwanted comedy show. But for me, knowing that Tiffany started as a person who was trying to deliver information about the movie, doesn't that change things? She was the one person trying to get answers to a problem that a whole room full of people shared. She was trying to pass on information, and it turned into this.
直到第二天蒂芙尼才知道她的一些观众并不领情，不想被迫欣赏一场不受欢迎的喜剧表演。但对我来说，知道蒂芙尼最初是一个试图传递关于电影信息的人，这难道没改变什么吗？她是唯一一个试图为全屋子人共享的问题寻找答案的人。她试图传递信息，结果变成了这样。
[SINGING OPERA]
（歌剧演唱）
Because this is who Tiffany is.
因为这就是蒂芙尼。
[SINGING OPERA]
（歌剧演唱）
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Here's what I was thinking when Tiffany recounted this experience to me. I was thinking about when I was at the airport, and I was instructed to stand in a line for a desk that had no person at it. I stood there anyway. A long line of other people stood there anyway, too, quietly, except for one woman, who could not bear it, who was actively, loudly shouting to everyone and no one walking by that we needed help.
当蒂芙尼向我叙述这段经历时，我想到的是这个。我想到我在机场时，被指示站在一个没有人办公的柜台排队。我还是站那儿了。后面长长的一排人也安静地站那儿，除了一个无法忍受的女人，她非常活跃、大声地向每个路过的人和没人喊我们需要帮助。
I kept looking down like, I'm not with her. But I was also glad for her, because ultimately, she got someone to help us, to tell us that we actually needed to go to a different desk, where there was a person where the printer was working. And the yelling woman, she led the way. We all followed her.
我一直低着头像是说，我不认识她。但我同时也为她感到高兴，因为最终，她找来人帮助我们，告诉我们实际上我们需要去另一个有人的、打印机能用的柜台。那个大喊的女人，她领路。我们都跟着她。
My point is, the person who takes it upon themselves to do something, they don't always do it in the way you would. They're not perfect, but neither are we, waiting in line for the desk with no person, or for the movie that's not starting.
我的重点是，主动承担去做某事的人，他们不总是以你会采用的方式去做。他们并不完美，但我们也不完美，在没有人办公的柜台，或没开始的电影前排队。
When you're sitting in a theater full of people who are not doing anything, is it as mystifying to you that people wouldn't want to do something as it is to someone like me that you would want to do something?
当你坐在一个什么都不做的剧院里时，人们不想做点什么这件事是否像我这样觉得你会想做点什么那样让你感到困惑？
When all this happened, I flashed back in my mind to a moment in high school when-- I think it was science class that we had to go into another room, talk to another class. And I think I sang opera for some reason, because I've had vibrato from early age. And my grandmother was a mariachi singer. And I remember this young guy being like-- or this kid my age-- being like, damn, Tiffany, you got some balls.
当这一切发生时，我脑子里闪过高中时的一个时刻——我想那是科学课，我们需要去另一个房间，和另一个班级谈话。我想我因为从小就有颤音，不知什么原因唱了歌剧。我祖母是墨西哥流浪歌手。我记得那个跟我同龄的年轻人像是——像是说，该死，蒂芙尼，你真有种。
So I don't think that the people that do anything that there's anything wrong with them, I just think that we all have a different purpose in life. And I feel that I have a purpose, which is to entertain and to lead people sometimes in certain situations. We need people-- we need go-getters. We need people that are going to solve problems, right? I was just trying to solve the problem and be helpful in the moment.
所以我不认为那些做任何事的人有什么问题，我只是认为我们在生活中都有不同的目的。我觉得我有一个目的，那就是在某些特定情况下娱乐大众并引领人们。我们需要人——我们需要进取者。我们需要那些能够解决问题的人，对吧？我只是在试图解决问题并在那一刻提供帮助。
I asked, did she consider that this was a situation where maybe no one needed help? Nobody needed to do anything. Tiffany said, no, the thought never crossed her mind, which I think is probably an important part of being a person who rushes to be helpful, a person who acts. You can't ask yourself that question.
我问，她是否考虑过这是一种或许没人需要帮助的情况？没人需要做任何事。蒂芙尼说，不，那个想法从未在她脑海里闪过，我认为这可能是成为一个冲着去提供帮助的人、一个行动者重要的一部分。你不能问自己那个问题。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "IF YOU GOT A PROBLEM" BY JOY OLADOKUN]
（音乐 - 乔伊·奥拉多昆演唱的《IF YOU GOT A PROBLEM》）
Today's program was produced by Lilly Sullivan and edited by Ben Calhoun. The people who put our show together include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Zoe Chase, Dana Chivvis, Michael Comite, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Joffe-Walt, Tobin Low, Michele Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Will Peischel, Alix Spiegel, Laura Starcheski, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior editor, David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由莉莉·沙利文制作，本·卡尔霍恩编辑。把节目拼凑在一起的人包括比姆·阿德温米、艾尔娜·贝克、佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇维斯、迈克尔·科米特、安德烈娅·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多、阿维瓦·德科恩费尔德、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、托宾·洛、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、威尔·佩舍尔、艾利克斯·斯皮格尔、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑，大卫·肯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
Special thanks today to Whitney Shefte, Kostyantin Khudov, Lesia Prokopenko, Christopher Solomon, Bryan Hance, Kate Swoger, Ali deGroot, Maggie Stapleton, Eric Dean Wilson, Sam Schiller, Joe Kremer, Melissa San Miguel, and Stacey King.
今天特别感谢惠特尼·谢夫特、科斯蒂安汀·胡多夫、莱西亚·普罗科彭科、克里斯托弗·所罗门、布莱恩·汉斯、凯特·斯沃格、阿里·德格鲁特、玛吉·斯台普顿、埃里克·迪恩·威尔逊、萨姆·席勒、乔·克雷默、梅丽莎·圣米格尔和斯泰西·金。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, of course, to my boss, Ira Glass.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX分发给公共广播电台。当然，感谢我的老板，艾拉·格拉斯。
When I started working here, I was nervous. And I said to him. I was like, what do you prefer? Should I call you Mr. Glass? Should I call you Ira, you know? And he's like, no, no, no, no. You can call me--
当我开始在这里工作时，我很紧张。我对他说了。我说，你更喜欢什么？我该叫你格拉斯先生吗？我该叫你艾拉，你知道吗？他说，不，不，不，不。你可以叫我——
Daddy!
爸爸！
I'm Sean Cole. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是肖恩·科尔。艾拉下周会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "IF YOU GOT A PROBLEM" BY JOY OLADOKUN]
（音乐 - 乔伊·奥拉多昆演唱的《IF YOU GOT A PROBLEM》）